in this video we're going to think about
the concept of minimum efficient scale
and then how that impacts market
concentration and we're going to make
sure we understand what both of these
ideas are so first of all minimum
efficient scale you can view it as the
smallest scale at which we stopped
getting economies of scale or another
way of thinking about it is the minimum
scale at which we are no longer our
long-run average total cost curve is
declining so in this example let's see
it when we talk about our taco trucks
when we were at about 80 units we're not
at minimum efficient scale yet because
our long-run average total cost curve is
still declining as we add more and more
and more units we're getting economies
of scale all the way until at least in
this example it looks like our long-run
average total cost curve stops declining
around 200 units so in this example that
would be our minimum efficient scale
which is sometimes abbreviated as M e s
and one way to think about it is this is
the minimum scale at which an operation
needs to run at in order to be very
competitive in order to be truly
efficient out there in the market
because you can imagine if some
operators are able to achieve minimum
efficient scale of let's say getting to
the 200 tacos a day while others are not
let's say they're only able to stay at
100 tacos per day and if the market were
to get very competitive and the price of
a taco were to go down to say 55 cents
per taco the people who are at minimum
efficient scale could still operate and
still make money while the people who
are not at minimum efficient scale well
they're not going to be able to
participate in the market and most
well-functioning markets it gets quite
competitive and so economists like to
think about what the minimum efficient
scale is and compare that to the entire
market size now what do we mean by
market size well it depends on how you
are defining the market in our example
of our taco trucks it might be the
market for tacos market
or tacos in our city and of course you
can define different markets you could
define it as the market for food trucks
in our city you could define it as the
market for tacos in our state or our
country but let's say if we were to say
the market for tacos in our city and
let's say that that market is ten
thousand ten thousand tacos per day well
in this reality our minimum efficient
scale is 200 tacos per day and it's a
very small fraction of the total market
and so that means that you could have
many different competitors each at that
minimum efficient scale so they're able
to produce tacos at that 50 cents per
taco and because of that you are likely
to have many competitors so when this
when our minimum efficient scale is a
small fraction of the total market that
is going to lead to fragmentation so
here we're going to have a fragmented
fragmented market so if this circle were
to represent the 10,000 tacos that are
sold per day if you're able to have a
lot of competitors each operating at
minimum efficient scale in fact there's
no real advantage to operating above
minimum efficient scale because then you
start getting dis economies to scale
well then you are going to have maybe 50
competitors who are splitting this
market so I won't take the trouble of
making us into 50 different chunks the
one competitor has that part of the
market other competitor has that part of
the market other competitor has that
part of the market and you could imagine
we're going to have this market
fragmented into maybe 50 different
players and so that's why it's called a
very fragmented market but let's say
that the minimum efficient scale was
pretty close to the market size so let's
say instead of a market for ten thousand
tacos per day let's say that the market
in our city is for four hundred four
hundred tacos per day well then the
market is going to be smaller like this
and so then it makes sense for if
someone's able to get to the minimum
efficient scale they can
take up a lot of the market in fact they
could take up half of the market so this
type of market might only be able to
really support two players in this
market so this is considered to be a far
more concentrated concentrated market
and you could go to a reality where your
minimum efficient scale is at the market
size or is even larger than the market
size so let's say that the market size
is not 400 tacos per day but let's say
we had to talk a market let's say we had
a market of 195 tacos per day per day
well in that world whoever can get to
195 tacos is going to produce most
efficiently they're not even getting to
the minimum efficient scale but the more
the closer that you can get to that
number you're going to have the lowest
average total long-run average total
cost of production and so it's going to
be very hard for anyone else to compete
with you especially if you're taking up
most of the market no one else is going
to be able to get to scale so they're
going to be operating out here on the
long-run average total cost curve and so
in that world you might only have one
player and when you have one player
where the market dynamics make it so
that it is actually efficient for only
one player this is sometimes referred to
as a natural monopoly there's other
dynamics that could lead to a natural
monopoly but one way to think about it
is is if you keep getting economies of
scale even up to the market size well
then whoever can get to that market size
first is going to be the most efficient
producer